hello to everyone from around the world
who's joining this intelligent square
plus event and it's a huge pleasure to
be able to
introduce this evening one of britain's
best known historians
who is of course resident across the
pond in the united states where he's
joining us from
today here's of course neil ferguson
neil has taught a variety of
distinguished institutions uh that would
include my own institution of oxford
university but since then he has
left out in all sorts of directions at
nyu at harvard
and most recently at stanford where he
is the milbank
family senior fellow at the hoover
institution
he's the author of 15 books time is
limited so i won't mention all of them
but amongst
the many that have attracted a great
deal of both scholarly
and public attention are the pity of war
the house of rothschild
uh empire civilization and of course the
big biography authorized of course of
henry kissinger
um the most uh the first volume 1923-268
titled the idealist uh he writes a
weekly
opinion column for bloomberg and he's
the founder and managing director of the
advisory firm
green mantle llc and his most recent
book
the square and the tower was a new york
times best seller i happen to have a
coffee
right here and having read and enjoyed
it very much i would recommend that you
uh watching go and do exactly the same
available at all good bookshops and even
at some
somewhat mediocre ones now tonight we're
going to have an hour of conversation
the first 30 minutes or so i am going to
steal privilege of
being able to talk to neil um 101
and the second half we're going to have
questions you've just heard from
chris but just a quick reminder that you
can start asking them
at any moment right now if you like on
the ask question
button just under the video screen and
then type in your question
if you want your name to be mentioned
hello there paris hilton then do
type into the box and press send if
you'd rather be anonymous
that's fine as well but please don't
type in green
font now today's topic
is looking at the way in which history
can help us to understand
the covid 19 pandemic and
neil a huge pleasure to be talking to
you and i have to say i couldn't think
of a better person to be
tackling this topic not least when i was
sent in advance what i think you call
your pandemic
deck of slides which i think is getting
up to close to a thousand slides which
must make for quite a power point i
imagine you have to hold your audience
hostage in in a sense but
it's part of what you call the pandemic
encyclopedia
and i'm wondering what were you thinking
when you put this together as a
historian were you sort of creating your
own
archive in the moment for when we can
look back on this pandemic
as a historic event well thanks
rana it's great to be with you and uh
one of the little silver linings in the
cloud of the covert 19 pandemic is that
one actually has more exchange with
people in distant places than
before i've noticed that my my
intellectual network
has been uh really quite radically
changed by
the fact that i'm stuck in one place but
able to zoom
or otherwise just about everywhere the
the key to this monstrous powerpoint
deck is that it's not
intended to be shown as as a
powerpoint presentation it's just the
way i take
notes and it has been the way that i
take notes
about for about 10 years since the
global financial crisis i i found that
the way i
could best keep track of history in real
time was
just to use powerpoint and that's
because i'm a graphs person as you know
ran i'd
love to illustrate points with uh with
with graphs and so the simple thing is
just to grab them wherever i see them
and
uh and grab text that i think might one
day be quotable so
these are my notes and i in this
particular case i started to compile
notes on covert 19 in mid-january
because i i was at the world economic
forum and i was
stunned to find this was in the middle
of january
that almost nobody there wanted to talk
about the impending pandemic
they wanted to have the usual
conversation about climate change
and i had just been in asia in the
second week of january i'd been in
in hong kong singapore and taipei and it
was very clear the conversations
that i had there and the things that i
was reading that we were in the very
early stages of a global pandemic i
wrote about it in my column
for the sunday times but it was the
skepticism
um that i encountered at davos that made
me start this particular deck so i
thought well i
i'm gonna write about this i might as
well start taking notes
and after a while i realized that i was
essentially performing a
a kind of public function i was doing
research
pretty intensively every day usually for
several hours
reading everything that i could get on
the subject not just of the virus but
more importantly to me
the social networks that it was
attacking and you mentioned the book the
square in the tower that the central
theme of that book is that a networked
world
is is vulnerable to contagions and not
just digital ones
after a certain point i realized that i
was doing something so useful i might as
well share it with friends
and and so i conducted a kind of
experiment in network science which was
i just sent it to all my friends and i
told them
it wasn't for publication because there
were lots of copyright material there
it's just purely
for educational purposes but they were
welcome to share it with anybody
of their friends that they thought would
find it useful and it's now grown to
i think it's not quite at 900 slides yet
um
and i suspended it last weekend because
i thought it was taking over my life
and it was time to probably call a halt
but in fact i continue to add to it
rather it's rather addictive and and of
course you've probably already guessed
this runner i'm going to write a book on
the on the basis of at least some of
this material
it does look very much like history in
the making and i have to say if you're
ever going to invite people around for
an evening viewing the slides uh perhaps
i might come in partway through the
event rather than at the beginning
considering how many there actually are
but having had a chance to flick through
the the deck i found various things that
actually seem very relevant to
historical perspective and somewhat
surprising
so let me give you an example of what i
found surprising
when you were talking about how to use
other pandemics in history as
comparators
the one that people tend to turn to at
the moment certainly seen in a lot of
the quality press uh in the last few
weeks
is the 1919 uh flu pandemic and there's
been a lot of discussion about that
you say at one point it's one of the
notes says at one point that actually
thinking about
1957 to 58 the so-called asian flu of
that era which is
unknown but not nearly as well known a
phenomenon as 1919
might be more useful why was that the
historical comparator that you wanted us
to think about
well 1918-19 is a a pretty famous
pandemic as you say rana it's the one
that's probably come up most often
once people realized it wasn't the black
death that we were facing
and this is probably the moment to
clarify for anybody
who's not sure that i'm not that neil
ferguson
n e i l ferguson uh the the
epidemiologist
at imperial college whose march 16th
paper
projected that without radical
interventions and
particularly lockdowns of uh of economic
life
the the covert 19 death toll could rise
as high as
half a million in the united kingdom and
2.2 million
in the united states now he didn't say
it explicitly but that implied that this
would be as bad as the 1918-19
influenza which began uh before the end
of
of the first world war and carried on
into into 1919 and indeed even
into 1920 in some studies this was a
cataclysmic uh pandemic one of the top
ten in history up there with
uh the black death though not not as
lethal in terms of the percentage of the
world's population it killed but it
probably killed somewhere between two
and three percent of
of the world's population uh it was a
very deadly influenza
uh virus it killed a very large
proportion of the people that it
infected
so the infection fatality rate was
probably around two maybe even higher
and uh and its devastation uh was
uh was global it was particularly deadly
in india
as well as causing havoc in a number of
south american and central american
countries
so when the other neil ferguson the
epidemic epidemiologist published that
paper
implying it was 1918-19 my immediate
reaction was
it's not it's just not it's not that it
can't be that deadly
uh it would be obvious by now if it were
that deadly
in addition to which uh it's not 1918-19
we have medical
capabilities that they didn't have then
they really had
very very few ways of treating people
who became ill with that influenza
the other thing to know about 1918-19
which is worth mentioning is that like
all
the influenza pandemics uh in history it
killed the very young as much as it
killed the very old and it killed a
really significant portion of people of
prime age
in fact one of the really awful things
about 1918-19 was it swept through the
armies
that were contesting the war beginning
in the u.s army and
and killed more american soldiers than
the war it's
itself so it was already obvious in
mid-march that covert 19 wasn't doing
that
it was disproportionately killing
elderly people that was already
clear so i began to suspect that the
other neil ferguson
had inadvertently drawn a wrong
historical analogy if you look back
through modern
pandemics you can find uh some better
analogues and i think the best one is
actually the 1957-58 influenza pandemic
just in terms of the proportions of
people that covet 19
is likely ultimately to kill i think
we're much closer to 5758
uh in the sense that uh we're probably
going to end up i would guess by the end
of this year
with roughly 200 000 americans dead of
covert 19. that would be my estimate
we're a little over halfway there at
this point
but if you go back to 5758 the death
toll according to the centers for
disease control was about 115 000.
so if you scale for a population it
looks like a comparable
impact at least in the united states and
i think that's also true
if you look at the global impact so i
think 5758 is a much better analogy
a less scary analogy because of course
there's a reason we don't remember
1957 1957-58 the reason is that it
didn't actually have
that big and that disruptive an impact
on the world
um and so i think it's probably worth
trying to learn
some lessons from that experience one of
them is that in the us they
did not do anything remotely like what
we've done
in response to this pandemic there were
no school closures there were
certainly no economic lockdowns life
went on
there was excess mortality but there was
almost no
real economic shock so that's one of the
obvious contrasts that
one can one can identify with that
comparison
i wonder neil how much culture as part
of history makes a difference too the
reason i ask that is that i had a piece
in the spectator magazine here in
britain
a couple of weeks ago about why south
korea has been one of the countries that
has been
so successful in managing to prevent
huge numbers of debts and
without um going to huge details about
the article amongst the things i looked
at were
not only the tech side the fact that
south korea is so wired for the internet
but also the way in which its confucian
society i think changed the way that it
thought about things like
old people's homes and care homes and
had a rather different way of putting
them into legislation
and the care that comes from them so
long-term as well as short-term issues
coming
together what do you think that we have
learned
about the importance if anything of
national culture or regional culture in
terms of
how the pandemic's been controlled is
there more that we could learn
well there is some research on this and
i touch on it towards the end of the
monster deck it's a
it's early days in in our thinking about
this but
uh a number of people have made this
argument that there's some kind of
difference
in culture between say confucian uh east
asians
and individualistic
and not very disciplined americans i
think it's not going to work that kind
of
analysis at least the the studies i've
seen so far don't really
come to satisfactory results because of
course there are
english-speaking countries like new
zealand for example that have handled
uh covert 19 just as well as as a as
south korea and i don't think of new
zealanders as being especially
confucian i'm pretty skeptical about
these cultural explanations because
there are better ones to hand
for example the south koreans like the
taiwanese have had learned
lessons from the experience of sars and
mars they had thought about
coronaviruses as a problem
and they'd understood that the key
response uh to something like this to a
novel coronavirus is very very
quickly to ramp up testing and contact
tracing
and indeed the taiwanese did an even
better job than the south koreans when
it came
to contact tracing which is why there
have been virtually no fatalities in
taiwan i think the
number of fatalities from covert 19 is
eight at this point
south korea had some super spreader
events this is a very important concept
we should probably come back to
but because of its testing and contact
tracing it was able to get on top of
them pretty quickly
and so what you see in countries like
taiwan and south korea is that the
government is equipped
to play whack-a-mole with uh with
outbreaks even if some citizens make
foolish mistakes as clearly happened in
some of the super spreader events
what's really striking is the lack of
the uh
of these capabilities uh in a number of
uh important countries uh the united
kingdom
and the united states stand out but
they're not alone
in having handled covered 19. badly
belgium
spain italy have had in relative terms
comparably bad uh if not worse
experiences
so i think uh it it really has much more
to do with did you learn the lessons
of sars and murders israel is
interesting because it seems to have
learnt the lessons
and i just made the argument earlier
today uh in a johns hopkins
conference that if you just look at the
rankings of countries who performed well
but what stands out is not a cultural
pattern or
for that matter a political pattern what
stands out is that these countries
are paranoid for a reason israel has
reasons to be paranoid taiwan has
reasons to be paranoid uh south korea
has reasons to be paranoid their
neighbors
are not the nicest of neighbours and
that has just meant that their defenses
are superior uh across a whole range of
of different
uh threat uh types uh and so i think
that might be a better explanation than
than any
cultural or for that matter political
explanation for these great
vari this great variance and performance
it's a good point it would also of
course explain the fact that north korea
claims i think to this day that it
hasn't had a single case of coronavirus
on
entirely reliable statistics i'm sure in
in every uh
every form let's they think a moment
about
policies because you talk about
countries that have handled it well and
badly and actually
the uk which is where i'm sitting now
has been controversial because it does
have a very
relatively pretty high rate per capita
but sweden of course just uh
north of the continent here took a very
very different policy it decided to
essentially
not have a lockdown at all and has had
a high rate but actually not much higher
than the uk
which did lock down very comprehensively
does that uk
sweden contrast show us anything that we
need to understand
yes it does i think the first thing is
that the the goal of herd immunity is uh
is a questionable objective in the face
of a
pathogen uh like sars cough ii the virus
that causes covert 19.
for a variety of reasons one of which is
it's just got this very low dispersion
factor this is the factor k in
epidemiological
uh jargon uh a very small proportion of
people do a very large
amount of the spreading there's also
great uh heterogeneity and
susceptibility and vulnerability through
the population
whereas herod immunity sort of assumes a
relatively homogeneous population and
you just need to get to a certain
threshold of having
had it and you and you're done this is a
very standard epidemiological model but
it doesn't really apply very well
uh in this case especially not if we
find that like other coronaviruses
saskoff 2 can give you immunity but not
for long
and i think there's a growing concern
that immunity will be a relatively short
lived thing
uh even for people who've who've had it
and got better
this might also be a problem with with
vaccinations so
herd immunity as as a goal of policy i
think was based on some
erroneous analogies that the public
health experts in a number of european
countries including the uk and sweden
were playing with the main main one
being its influenza
and i think what went wrong in in
britain and perhaps also in sweden was
the belief that we were dealing with
something quite similar
to an influenza virus as opposed to
being
something quite different namely a
coronavirus
the other thing that's really striking
here is that and this is
something the oxford blavatic school
your colleagues just down the road from
you have have shown brilliantly
that there is no correlation between the
stringency of government measures
and outcomes none at all there's a
correlation between the stringency of
government measures
and economic outcomes but not outcomes
in terms of the containment
of the spread the swedish british
comparisons fascinating because
you end up at a very similar place in
many ways certainly in terms of
cases relative to population but britain
uh conducts a complete u-turn in policy
ditches herd immunity reads the other
neil ferguson's report and
panics and britain goes down the road of
really drastic
lockdowns shutting down uh the economy
as completely as almost any country
has done with as as you can imagine huge
attendant costs
but the payoffs in terms of containment
of the contagion
have been pretty dismal and if you take
a measure like excess mortality which is
a pretty good measure
i.e how much more death has there been
than you would have expected on the
basis of
say the last five years then april and
may in britain stand out as
pretty horrendous by the standards of
any developed country
britain has had one of the highest
excess mortality
spikes of anywhere apart from countries
in latin america like
peru that have had really disastrous
experiences
so i think when we try to learn lessons
from what's happened in britain
and there really need to be a proper
commission of inquiry
one of the most obvious lessons will be
that the key to success with this
particular pathogen was not really a
particular strictness
of of policy uh it had a lot more to do
with the ways in which
people adapted their behavior and i
think that that's probably where the
conversation is going to go certainly in
the literature that i read
we're seeing that in countries like
taiwan and south korea it wasn't just
that the government was doing
testing and contact tracing well it was
also that citizens adapted their
behavior
mask wearing was very quickly adopted
japan is an interesting case here a
very big country which has a very very
uh
limited uh covert 19 trouble uh
two orders of magnitude smaller in
relative terms
why not really because the japanese
government did a brilliant job of
testing and contract racing it didn't
but just because the japanese population
adapted very quickly
particularly with respect to mask
wearing so i think when we come back to
understanding
what's happened in britain part of the
story is
really a failure of behavior to adapt
and i think we still see that
and we've seen the same in the united
states the difference
interestingly rana is that in the united
states people have been
itching to get back to normal especially
people in
red states republican states what i see
in britain is actually something quite
different
people are not in a hurry to get back to
normal they've actually been quite
scared by
what they've been told about the disease
and there isn't a great appetite so far
as i can see
to do anything other than to get back to
the beach on a sunny day
not to get back to work there may of
course be other reasons why people are
not uh
um tripping over themselves to get back
to the office but we perhaps shouldn't
uh delve too far into those personal
motivations but
it does bring up the question which you
already mentioned neil of the economy
and how that's changed things and you're
of course speaking to us from
the united states and it does appear
that
more than any other country and
certainly more than the uk or another
european country
the pandemic has become a partisan issue
i mean over here we're reading these
reports that essentially mask wearing
you've just mentioned
it's becoming it's compulsory here in
britain on public transport for instance
and people are adapting without too much
grumbling and
you wouldn't be able to i think pin that
to any particular type of politics
particularly since the current
government is in fact
a conservative one but that mask issue
seems to be symbolic
of a much bigger divide in the us
between democrats and republicans
that's right and it's of course part of
our national story at the moment in the
united states
everything is a partisan issue and
covert 19 became one
quite early on polling shows and it has
shown for several months that democrats
worry much more
about the disease cropping up in their
neighborhood than republicans do the
difference is absolutely massive
uh and that has uh spread it's
from the behavioral changes that there
have been so
i i have friends in uh various southern
states i was speaking to
philip bobert who's in texas uh right
uh right now only this morning and he
said to me
he'd just been out in in the
neighborhood nobody is wearing masks in
texas
and nobody's wearing masks in georgia
and indeed one of my friends who's in
fact a new yorker
is spending a plague year in georgia was
was commenting that
he's harassed he has to deal with
with abuse when he wears a mask in the
stores it's become
a sign of being uh a libtard to use the
argo of the far right
to wear a mask and that is of course
something that uh president trump has
only encouraged by declining to wear a
mask
himself so this this is part of the
pathology of modern america that that
even responses to a novel pathogen
become
partisan it's interesting actually rana
we we've been doing some work on this at
green mantle the
the return of of the normal mobility is
something that
helps us understand how quickly the
economy is recovering
and thanks to google and apple and
companies like safegraf we have amazing
high frequency data on how much people
are moving around as normal
and if you look at returns to retail and
recreation destinations which are
reasonable proxy for consumer behavior
the fascinating thing is that if you go
down to the county level
counties that lent trump words back in
2016 have returned almost immediately to
they're very close to normal
in terms of mobility to recreational and
retail
uh destinations but counties that lent
democrat that lent clinton four years
ago have not in fact there's
there's about a ten percentage point gap
and so what we're seeing here is
actually a
partisan recovery where republicans are
recovering economically faster than
democrats
and consequently a partisan second wave
of infections
because in the states where these sort
of trends are most pronounced
you're also seeing second waves of
infection and hospitalization
and that is i think that's really the
big story of the last week or so
the realization that americans
particularly republicans supporting
americans
return it to normality are in fact uh
igniting a second wave of covert 19.
let me pick up on one aspect of that
though neil because one of the things
that also surprised me from your your
monster deck because i think we're
learning to call it um
was that while you're clearly not
particularly impressed by the way in
which president trump has been
engaging with the covid crisis you're
not one of the people who actually puts
the blame
firmly on him in terms of it spreading
as far as it has you see a much more
institutional reason in the us for why
the disease spread as fast and as
destructively as it has
so why was that well i think it's worth
saying rana that the media on both sides
of the atlantic have done a shockingly
bad
job um sorry to any journalists
listening
in covering the pandemic they've made it
almost all about a handful of
personalities
donald trump in the united states boris
johnson and dominic cummings in the uk
and this is just to misunderstand how
public health emergency
look the critical institutions are not
right at the the people right at the top
the critical institutions are
those responsible for public health
there are people
with the job in the case of the united
states uh the job of pandemic
preparedness at the assistant secretary
level in the department of
health and human services the guy's name
is robert cadleck and you've never heard
of him
because there's been almost no media
coverage of his role
and what i found fascinating uh and i
delved into this
with the encouragement of my old friend
philip zeliko who
who sat on or was involved with the 911
commission
philip pointed me to the fact that the
institutions whose
job this was have failed dhhs
failed cdc failed i mean the center for
disease
control was supposed to be responsible
for ramping up testing
in a situation like this it did just the
opposite it actually
held testing back uh in the early phase
of the pandemic
so i think what most people have missed
in their excessive focus on on president
trump who's clearly made a series of
pretty terrible judgments
what they've missed is that the real
system failure
happened much further down the chain of
command
with those parts of the bureaucracy we
sometimes call it the deep state these
days
responsible for pandemic preparedness
and one of the fascinating things is
that
on paper the us and the uk were amongst
the best prepared countries for a
pandemic
on paper there were endless reports
there were powerpoint decks for that
matter
in 2018 i think there was a 36-page
pandemic preparedness
report i've plowed through it it all
reads very well
but when there actually was a pandemic
the bureaucracy failed completely and i
that will be the subject again of of
future historical and probably also
public
public inquiry i think this is a really
really important point
uh the great physicist richard feynman
wrote a wonderful account of his role in
the
investigation into the great space
shuttle challenger disaster
it's a classic everyone should read it
now you couldn't really blame that or at
least not very easily on
ronald reagan who was president at the
time but you have to actually read
feynman to see
that the point of failure that led to
the challenger disaster
was the mid-level nasa bureaucrats who
ignored the warnings from the engineers
who were saying again and again that
there was a 101-100 chance that the
thing would blow up
in the same way there were plenty of
people i mean i was one of them
warning that there was a real problem
back in january
um but something went terribly wrong
just as it did with the challenger
in the department of health and human
services and you can't pin that all on
trump
indeed to take a risk and say something
in president trump's defense always a
mistake
with a predominantly european audience
trump's instinct at the end of january
was to close off
travel from china and he actually banned
passengers
from china from coming into the u.s
there was a huge
wave of indignation in the liberal media
about this endless pieces in the
washington post and the new york times
etc saying
what a dreadful piece of racism this was
the only thing wrong with trump's
decision was that it was about two weeks
too late he should really have stopped
the planes coming from china
about two weeks earlier in mid uh in
mid-january
by the end of january it was too late
but on his instincts there were not
actually wrong and he was castigated for
it well you mentioned china neil and
that brings up what looks to me at this
moment
as if it may be one of the great winners
if we could even use that expression
of the covert 19 pandemic because three
or four months ago in february
you will know this very well not because
i know you keep an eye on these things
chinese social media was really hitting
on president xi jinping
there were people talking about the fact
that it might be possible that his his
grip on rule might be loosened in some
way
four five months later he's now clamping
down in hong kong
the disease appears as far as we can
tell to be broadly under control in
china although there are
isolated flare-ups china is now
exercising what's become known as the
the jan lang the wolf warrior diplomacy
in which
basically is you know shouting at the
world doesn't really care what the world
says back
is it actually china and not the us that
may end up coming out of this thinking
we are the geopolitical masters now well
that is
certainly the consensus view i wish i
had a
bitcoin for every article i've read in
the last two months saying
it's all over for the united states
kishore marbabani was right the asian
century is here
china is the winner we've all had to
learn from china authoritarian regimes
turn out to be better than
democracies all this stuff has been said
by many people including very
eminent people in fact i i see a kind of
revival of
declinism in american journalism lots
and lots of
arguments almost cyclical theories of
history predicting
the downfall of of the united states and
the triumph of xi jinping
and i'm absolutely sure this will turn
out to be wrong
uh for a couple of reasons uh one
i think that the damage that this has
done to china
is a good deal greater than meets the
western
eye not just in terms of the damage
it has done to xi jinping's legitimacy
which i agree has ceased to be
a major talking point but actually
i think it's more profound than that i
think that it's very difficult indeed
now for china to sustain growth at the
rates
uh it was planning to and indeed they
had to as you know rana scrap their
growth target for this year which means
they can't
meet the the cherished objective of
doubling gdp in 10 years
and in order to make the unemployment
numbers look better they've just
re-legalized street vendors which is
hardly the cutting edge of
of economic technologies i think there's
something quite
seriously wrong at the heart of the
chinese economy
apart from in that high-tech
online world where chinese companies are
in many ways the equals of the big tech
companies of silicon valley
the rest of the chinese economy is i
think in serious trouble
and the fact that they just about had to
shut down beijing last week because of a
new outbreak
should not be dismissed likely
whack-a-mole is going to make it very
hard for the
chinese economy to have anything like a
v-shaped recovery and they're going to
be playing whack-a-mole with this virus
i think into next year the second thing
i'd
i'd say is that the wolf warrior
diplomacy which you
alluded to this extraordinary shrill
tone that
some younger chinese diplomats have
adopted
i think it's a sign of a dangerous
hubris
uh it hasn't worked very well in fact
they succeeded in alienating the french
and the germans completely
with their uh their social media antics
back at the height of the pandemic in in
europe
but i think more seriously what worries
me at the moment is
that they are underestimating the united
states uh
and they are i think embarking on what
could be a very risky strategy
not so much with respect to hong kong
which i don't think is the key flash
point but with respect to taiwan
and i think the general tendency which
you now see in chinese social media and
you will know this
better than i do uh is to disparage
trump to mock him
to suggest that he's a kind of
manchurian candidate who's helping china
on its way to dominance i think this
could lead to some very serious
miscalculations i think the second half
of 2020 is going to see a major
geopolitical crisis
probably over taiwan and i think that
the chinese are
taking a major risk if they think that
they could
in fact simply take over taiwan solve
their problem which is of course that
they rely heavily
on semiconductors from the taiwanese
company tsmc
and get away with it because trump has a
busted flush
i think this is the risk that china runs
that it's actually going to
make a major geopolitical mistake and i
sense that the
the atmosphere in beijing is very
conducive to that kind of miscalculation
i'm sure that's uh that's right we
should move in just a moment or two
to audience questions but since we're on
this subject um i'll add first of all
that there are of course voices in china
most recently in public uh the foreign
vice foreign minister for ying
also the uh chinese ambassador in the us
who've actually spoken out quite
strongly against this very shrill
really aggressive wolf warrior rhetoric
and i pointed out it's doing china no
good so
that may indicate at least some level of
internal
unease about the way in which that's
that's going the last question i throw
at you
because um i think it's one that will be
occupying all of us
in a few months time whether we want it
or not is do you think that
a trump victory or a biden victory makes
any difference when it comes to
the u.s china relationship and just for
the kicker on that
what do you think that u.s china
relationship is likely to be
in the next let's say two to three years
well i think it's going to make less of
a difference
than might be assumed by europeans who
tend to hate on republican presidents
and
unlike democrats at the moment uh if
anything
the biden campaign is trying to sound
more hawkish than trump on china they're
making much of the
obviously very embarrassing revelations
of john bolton's
uh new book which uh make it clear that
uh that trump privately in meetings with
xi jinping is prepared to
make all kinds of concessions in order
to enhance his chances of re-election
but i think the most telling piece of
evidence in this respect uh is a recent
article by michel fluenoy in foreign
affairs
michelle is likely to be uh if there is
indeed a biden victory secretary of
defense
the tone of this piece uh was if
anything more hawkish than
some of the things one hears from the
republican side it was a very very clear
statement that the united states needs
to be able to deter
china in areas like the taiwan strait of
the south china sea and the critique
of the trump administration was that it
wasn't being tough enough
on those issues added to which i think
the biden administration would be bound
to be more concerned
about human rights issues democrats
always are
think back to bill clinton and the the
butchers of beijing so i think that
biden will try to run
uh as a more hawkish candidate than
trump on the china issue
and remember the american public is in a
hawkish mood and there's been a huge
shift in sentiment on china in the last
couple of years i think largely in fact
because donald trump has led it uh it's
ironic that he now finds himself on the
defensive on this issue especially given
joe biden's record as as vice president
uh
under uh barack obama who in the end
gave up on the idea of a pivot to asia
and any real containment of
of china's rise so i think the one thing
to to emphasize here is that there'll be
a change on trade policy
i'm pretty sure that the democrats would
resurrect the tpp
trans-pacific partnership and uh ditched
the whole idea of using tariffs as a
as a way of achieving any uh any
progress with china but on the broader
issue of what i call
cold war ii which i think has now been
going for at least a couple of years
i don't think cold war ii is going to
end if joe biden is inaugurated in
january
and it stays cold do you think rather
than going further
the war well i think the risk of of a
cold war is always that it can get hot
that was what made the cold war so
nerve-wracking
when it was the soviet union on the
other side and my sense is that
there is a potential uh for a hot war
uh most likely over taiwan graham
allison my
former colleague at harvard just
published a good piece in national
review saying
that the sanctions on huawei that the
commerce department
announced a few weeks back which will
come into effect in september
are comparable to the oil embargo
imposed
on japan by the uh by the us in 1941
which of course was the thing that drove
japan
as you know better than anyone uh to the
reckless uh
gamble of of war uh that began with
pearl harbor
i think this is a really interesting
analogy and and it's true that when you
when you think about the issue that
could really trigger a hot war
at that taiwan has has all the hallmarks
of a kaza's belly
not least of which uh is the fact that
that the us
doesn't really have a credible deterrent
strategy here michelle florina is almost
certainly right
and if you read a book like christian
ambrose's new new book the kill chain
he basically says the same right now the
u.s has a commitment to the defense of
taiwan that it can no longer credibly
enforce because us aircraft carrier
groups would be very vulnerable
uh to anti-uh to to anti-ship missiles
uh fired from the chinese mainland it's
always those situations isn't it rana
that lead to war
when the the rising power isn't actually
adequately deterred by the incumbent
power and that's why it's
taiwan that worries me the most i think
we're another entire audience extremely
nervous neil perhaps is just where uh
where you want them at this this point
and they are certainly firing in
questions uh just like uh a uh an
assault battery on the coast of taiwan
one might say uh at least if things go
really
really so let's get straight to our
audience's questions and the first one
comes in from
joseph clemo who actually is asking a
very historically informed question and
the specific
is was the black death a possible cause
of the renaissance then he follows up
and do major social changes uh
which presumably caused by disease or
other major disasters actually have long
lasting effects
this is a great question and really
requires a medievalist
to answer it properly i'll have a
go as an an amateur i mean many of the
things that that we
call the renaissance that we associate
with the
the italian city-states we're already
underway
prior to the 1340s uh if you think
say of of siena and what has had already
been achieved there
both in terms of of politics uh as well
as political thought
uh the renaissance had had started
and in that sense uh the black death was
a huge interruption
uh of of intellectual life uh of course
it gave creative opportunity to picacho
but i think on
on balance the effects of the black
death were
negative not not positive uh there were
whole cities that essentially were were
depopulated towns that
that had a population collapsed to near
zero
uh and uh and even the big cities uh
uh venice uh and florence for example
suffered really heavy uh mortality
because of course there was no real
understanding of what it was
that that was causing uh these outbreaks
of
bubonic plague so it's hard to believe
that on balance
uh the black death uh was was somehow
good for
cultural uh development it had all kinds
of important effects
uh that i'll mention too uh by creating
massive
labor shortages it definitely had uh
the effect of of at least improving the
bargaining power of
of europe's uh peasant population uh
although efforts
to to to resist uh those bargaining
efforts uh those bargaining moves led to
that's a conflict in in england
culminating in the in the peasants
revolt all
sorts of uh of things that i studied as
an undergraduate at oxford and
haven't really worked on since so i
tread warily and defer
to the experts the second the second
thing of course is that
in trying to understand how to manage a
pandemic
uh the black death taught city-states in
particular but states more generally the
importance of being able to enforce
uh quarantines the term dates from that
that period
uh and manage flows of people so some
increase in state
capacity followed uh followed from the
black death but the final part of your
question is the broader one which i'm
probably better equipped to answer
and do pandemics have a big cultural
consequences and i i think here you know
it's a really interesting question
because some do and some don't i know
that's a rather lame
lame observation but you you'd struggle
to find any lasting consequences
of the 1957-58 influenza pandemic
on the other hand i think there's some
evidence that 1918
did have an impact uh one paper i read
recently made the point that
in countries that had really been
hammered by the 1980-19 influenza
pandemic
levels of trust of social capital were
reduced for
a generation or or more i'll add one
point
uh one final point the cultural
consequences
of the hiv aids pandemic a much slower
moving pandemic than covert 19 but a
deadlier one
to date are i think worth reflecting on
if we try to ask ourselves
how will our lives be changed by covert
19 for
the long term i think the answer will be
that covert 19 will be to our social
lives
what hiv aids was to sexual life
uh that is to say it will modify
behavior but not enough
uh safe sex did not become universal
that's why ultimately more than 30
million people have died
of aids in the last three decades and i
don't think there will ever be safe
social life
so that as long as covert 19 is around
and we don't have
a vaccine and we don't have effective
therapies then there will be
outbreaks and there will be mortality so
that that seems like the best answer i
can give to that question
there's nothing about medieval history
by the way um
if anyone um hasn't read it an absolute
classic from about 40 50 years ago w
h mcneil's plagues and people as one of
the first books that really
set historians on the road to
understanding how disease and social
change
often positive social change could
interact and just a reminder to our
audience
about asking questions we're still very
happy to to take them uh just underneath
the video screen you'll see a tab
saying ask a question click on it text
box will be there
pop your question in there give us your
name if you want it and then click
send and we will add it to our queue we
probably won't get through all of them
but we'll try and get through
as many as possible and do tweet us uh
using the hashtag
iq2 now let's go back to the questions
which are coming in here
neil and here's one uh now this is much
more uh
directly on your historical expertise so
no no sashaying away from this one i
think and it's from harvey toomey
the question is i have heard you neil
recently draw comparison with china
today and imperial germany
over a century ago could you expand on
this not least because i've seen bob
kagan has been using this comparison for
quite some time now
so over to harvey's question i think
neil
and not only uh bob kagan but
also henry kissinger if you remember in
on china
kissinger concludes with the air crew
memorandum
and very explicitly suggests that uh
the united states and china might risk
replaying
the history of uh of the united kingdom
and
germany uh which produced the the war of
1914 so this is a
this is a really interesting uh
historical analogy
and one that i've written about myself i
think this goes back to what we were
talking about earlier rana the the the
mood in
in beijing and that possible hubris
uh that that one one sees at least
amongst
some uh chinese uh diplomats
that's very vil hermine and and hermione
germany had
a number of of rather chinese modern
chinese characteristics
not only a sort of explicit desire for
world policy which
i think xi jinping has has made very
much a part of his his
act uh one belt one road is the the kind
of chinese equivalent of
of belt politik also this sense that if
you have
domestic social tensions if inequality
is an issue
then what better way to distract
people's attention than to
bestride the globe and assert your uh
your geopolitical parity with the
dominant
uh english-speaking superpower from a
british vantage point what made us
nervous about germany before 1914 was
partly
the extraordinary speed of the german
economy's growth the the sense that
technologically
they were pulling ahead the ubiquity of
made in germany
on the goods that the people purchased
in pre-1914 britain well that sounds
distinctly familiar for americans made
in china has played much the same
role and the sense of falling behind
china
technologically is is i think one of the
things that haunts
americans when they contemplate the rise
of china's i
i do think this is a useful analogy
maybe the best of the analogies in
graham allison's uh book destined for
war
if there is a thucydides trap uh that
the united states and china are heading
towards it does look a lot like the one
that britain and germany
fell into just over a hundred years ago
it's on from that neil it's not about
rivals but it's about
partnership and the question is if china
and russia become
increasingly dominant and they carve up
the globe
russia to europe for instance i guess
china to asia
would they avoid conflict or would an
actual conflict emerge between the two
of them sooner rather than later
this is a great question and it reminds
us
that the geopolitical consequences of a
pandemic are often the
hardest to predict historically it's
worth saying that that pandemic said
were more likely to stop wars than to
start them
armies that had to throw in the towel
because of typhus
are very numerous in the history books
but i think in the modern era this is
less of a constraint
and i i do sense that one of the things
we're seeing at the moment
is geopolitical risk taking by russia as
well as by china
now they are as close together as as
they have ever been
from a geopolitical standpoint the
relationship between vladimir putin and
xi jinping is really one of the
strongest
though i'm sure it is a marriage of
convenience not of love
and i do think that the russians have
been teaching the chinese a thing or two
in the last four years about information
warfare because we're seeing
the chinese engage in very russian style
tactics on social media
these days so i think one should assume
that they are a very tight
partnership right now and the big worry
from a u.s point of view
is that any move that the chinese may
make in east asia
would probably be matched by a russian
move
maybe in the baltic states that would be
very risky for putin
more likely in north africa in the
middle east where the russians are
already running riot
after all the partition of libya is one
of the less well-covered events of 2020
but it's essentially happening between
russian proxies and turkish
proxies and i think from putin's point
of view
the discovery which dates back to the
urban administration
that the post-american middle east was
going to be a place where russia could
be a power broker
has really been a very important
development and much
underrated by by analysts of the
geopolitical scene
now i don't think russia are going to
triumph
i actually think the weaknesses of both
these states are going to become
much more visible and in a few years
time
people will say oh that neil ferguson
was very prescient when he said that
wuhan was china's chernobyl wasn't he
but for now i'm going to be the
contrarian who says
this is doing more damage to china than
to the united states i don't actually
expect
any good to come of russo-chinese
risk-taking i think it will backfire on
them
because they're underestimating the us's
capabilities
and they're underestimating the alliance
systems which will hold up despite
donald trump's obvious uh disdain for
them
ultimately it's very hard to believe
that russia and china will be
a marriage that lasts there are all
kinds of suspicions on each side
for obvious historical reasons so one of
the other things i would anticipate
is that when it all goes wrong and i
think it will go wrong for xi jinping
and vladimir putin
that particular partnership will
geopolitically come to an end
just one very quick follow-up on that
thought which has to do actually
something you mentioned earlier uh neil
which is the idea of china's belt and
road as
well politik a large part of the first
phase of china's belt and road
initiative
actually is russia's backyard it's the
stands it's central asia
and surely that must be a potential
conflict point between that well not
necessarily
in terms of hot war but in terms of that
lack of trust that you were mentioning
and that's what if you talk to russians
privately they
most dislike about the she putin
bromance
uh they sense that uh that really gains
that russia made
going all the way back to the 19th
century are being eroded
by by china and because putin has
committed himself
in ukraine in syria and now in libya he
has
absolutely nothing that he can do he has
to suck it up
if the chinese decide to assert
themselves in russia's historic backyard
and i do think that's the
fatal flaw of putin's grand strategy
frankly
i would just say that when i'm in
private conversations with the russians
after the third bottle of vodka i
remember nothing about what they've said
geopolitical
or otherwise but moving hastily on to
marcelo's question
neil i think i'm not breaking any
secrets here to say that you are an
expert on money and its history and
marcella's question is
how do you think monetary policy and the
concept of money will evolve after the
pandemic eg
do you think that helicopter money will
become an acceptable response
uh is there gonna be more virtual more
digital where do you see
the the next ascent of money from steal
your phrase may go
well i had a fascinating conversation on
this very subject yesterday with raul
powell
real vision i think this is a kind of
financial revolution that we're
living through and it predates the the
pandemic but the pandemic's accelerating
it in various ways
let me pick out three uh the first
is that uh because of the economic shock
that
uh the pandemic caused amplified by
lockdowns
policies that used to be regarded as
fringe
are kind of uh marginal uh have become
mainstream
in effect uh we are doing modern
monetary theory
uh in effect we are doing universal
basic income
central banks uh are not quite
monetizing debt in the old sense because
uh what they're doing when they buy
bonds as in the financial crisis
is to pay with a special kind of money
which is
uh bank reserves interest bearing bank
reserves it's not as if they're
really dropping uh the money from the
sky
metaphorically but we've certainly moved
in the direction of dropping money from
the sky
uh most obviously in in china where
citizens are essentially just given
digital spending power and told to go
off and use it in an attempt to generate
consumption the second financial
revolution
that i think we're seeing is that
online banking online financial activity
is going to
displace traditional branch banking and
it's going to do it very rapidly in some
places
because the truth is you really don't
need to go into the branch of nat west
to do uh your basic financial
transactions you could do it all
perfectly well online
uh with the decent uh neo bank that that
that's definitely being speeded up
uh by the by the pandemic and and
finally i think the fascinating
uh sort of uh development is that
cryptocurrencies which uh
some people were writing off uh just a
few
uh years ago after the bitcoin bubble
burst
uh are in fact uh benefiting uh from the
great uncertainty that's been been
aroused particularly in some
uh in some parts of the world where it's
not clear that the basic institutions of
of uh of government will withstand the
pandemic and so you see
that bitcoin has been a pretty good
store of value comparable in fact
to gold in 2020 uh contrary to the
predictions of people who just a couple
of years ago
uh were were predicting that bitcoin
would go to zero that that i knew would
be wrong and i i said it would be wrong
in my
updated ascent of money which was
published in 2018. incidentally rana
the new edition of the ascent of money
which had two new chapters covering
the yet the years from lehman brothers
all the way to 2018 concluded by
predicting correctly that the next big
crisis would come from
china what i didn't uh foresee that it
would take the form of uh
of a novel coronavirus well like dominic
cummings perhaps you could always go
back
reprint all the versions and then send
them out again as if they'd be in the
original it is alleged he says hastily
just a reminder to our audience that you
can ask a question uh by clicking on the
ask
question button under the video screen
and then press send
and don't forget you can also tweet us
on iq2
still a bit of time and still definitely
questions coming in and actually link to
your last point
neil there's a rather nice follow-on
here that comes from charlie
and that is what do you think the
political consequences will be for the
uk
going forward by which he means it's a
conservative government or so that's the
label on the tin but in fact it seems to
be operating
post-war socialism-style government and
of course
we've heard that both michael gove and
now i think boris johnson have been
citing fdr
as their new economic and political
pin-up as to where the uk is going next
um did you predict that at the end of uh
center money
[Music]
i i didn't i must confess foresee
uh that uh the boris johnson my old
oxford contemporary would become
prime minister and that he would go with
remarkable speed from hero to zero
uh because of uh of a pandemic
originating in wuhan i'm not nostradamus
for god's sake
but i think what's fascinating about the
the consequences for britain
is that they don't need to play out
politically
for such a long time in the united
states the day of reckonings just months
away
but because of the fixed term
parliament's act boris can go through a
period of intense unpopularity
and still be prime minister and unless
of course the clearly very ambitious
rishi sunak finds out some
some way of of knifing him and uh and
pushing him to one side
i do think if if if i were if i were
boris i'd be a little worried about
uh having promoted rishi sunak so
rapidly
one sure way to become popular in the
united kingdom is to send people a lot
of money for not working
and that has been the key i think to
rishi sunak's meteoric rise as i
mentioned earlier
it's not as if the great british public
is itching to get back
to work unlike their american
counterparts so the conservatives have
have landed themselves yeah you might
say with
uh it's tori tori men are not so much
wig
measures as distinctly progressive
uh uh if not in some respects socialist
measures and the challenge is going to
be
how do you wind this down when you can
finally say with a sigh of relief that
the pandemic is
over or at least that you've managed to
to contain it
and nobody has a good answer to that
that question my own view is that
sooner or later all countries will will
have to reckon with the very large debts
that they've accumulated
um which which i i think cannot be
financed at current
uh nominal rates indefinitely just seems
to me highly implausible
that we'll have these rates forever and
at some point
we're going to be back to the old
arguments that we used to have in the in
the days of george osborne remember him
about what it was that you would have to
do to bring
public finances back onto a sustainable
path
i predict we'll be having those
arguments within the conservative party
in the next couple of years and let's
face it now
you know kiyostama has lots of time to
practice
for the role of tony blair which at some
point i suspect he's going to take on
the centrist leader uh who's
sufficiently
uh palatable to the middle class that he
can be prime minister
but it's frustrating for him he's got a
long wait ahead of him and and
opposition is just
it's just a lot less fun than than
government although it does appear that
kiersten
in his first few weeks is having quite a
lot of fun with it perhaps a bit
uh a bit more than people came to expect
we will see how
he and boris johnson uh face off against
each other for quite some number of
years
to come we and our audience here i think
could carry on for ages and ages but i
think time is going to defeat us
so i'm going to thank neil uh neil
ferguson very much
indeed for having spent an hour with us
to give us his insights from history
from the present day and even about the
future as he's pointed out
he's not nostradamus nostradamus had
much longer beard than you did
neil yours is much more trim and suave
and spelt in every way i should
add but in terms of giving us food for
thought and
the material for plenty more
intelligence squared conversations and
of course books to read
we're very grateful to have had your
time it's wonderful that so many people
from around the world have joined us
tonight at intelligent
squared and many thanks to intelligence
squared who also
are in a lockdown of their own they
can't uh we can't hold live
intelligence squared events at the
moment but these online events
are becoming a bit of sort of an
invented tradition i suppose and it's
very very good we have them as well
so thank you everyone who's joined us
tonight